les injonctions à il faut absolument
regarder ces images et je vais je dirais
je regarderai qui est là et qui est pas
là je trouve que c'est très dangereux de
faire ça parce que ça renvoie à des
choses très personnelles notamment il y
a un député Renaissance Éric botorel
spécialiste du terrorisme et des
questions numériques qu'il a très bien
exprimé sur Mia part il y a quelques
jours en disant en fait c'est en tout
au-delà de la guerre des images et je
suis d'accord avec ça tout ça c'est en
tour de choses importantes de corpus
raison pour laquelle par exemple au
procès du 13 novembre on a refusé de
diffuser les images c'est pas parce que
on ne veut pas voir la réalité c'est pas
parce que c'est parce qu'en fait il y a
des êtres humains derrière tout ça y
compris les députés en sont et les
sénateurs donc je pense c'est très
compliqué en fait de de tirer un un un
une conclusion politique à ce qui s'est
passé là autour de ces images bien merci
merci beaucoup à tous les deux d'avoir
participé à ce face à faceace nous
sommes à quel quelques secondes du début
des questions au gouvernement c'est
l'heure de rejoindre Audrey vuetas qui
se trouve dans l'hémicycle du Sénat
Audrey pour dire un mot et bien des
thématique de cette séance qui s'annonce
oui Tam on vient de voir Aurélien
Rousseau le ministre de la Santé qui
s'est installé et beaucoup de questions
l'attendent aujourd'hui et oui les
sénateur examine en ce moment le projet
de loi sur le financement de la sécurité
sociale et beaucoup de questions
porteront sur ce sujet elles viendront
notamment des Rand de la gauche question
de Bernard jaumier qui demandera des
précisions sur les manques du texte
selon lui de Corine Ferré qui évoquera
l'écroulement de l'hôpital public mais
vous avez entendu la sonnerie le
président du Sénat devrait arriver et la
toute première question sera posée par
Pascal Alizard le sénateur LR qui vient
de me communiquer sa question elle
portera sur l'ingérence étrangère dans
l'augmentation des actes
antisémites merci merci beaucoup Audrey
pour et bien toutes ses explications sur
cette séance intendie que l'on voit et
bien Gérard Larcher qui vient de sortir
du cabinet de départ pour rejoindre
l'hémicycle du Sénat le président du
Sénat qui va donc ouvrir cette séance de
questions au gouvernement avec vous
disiez beaucoup de questions sur les
inondations une question sur
l'antisémitisme notamment et bien la
suite de la marche de dimanche dernier
et puis on le disait donc cette question
qui va ouvrir cette séance de questions
de Pascal alizar une question de diplômé
mer pascalard sénateur les républicain
et vice-président de la commission des
affaires étrangères de la commission de
la défense on prend tout de suite la
direction la séance est
ouverte le contendu analytique de la
précédente séance a été
distribué nous n'avons pas reçu
d'observation il y en a-t-il en
séance je n'en vois point le
procèsverbal est donc adopté sous les
réserves
d'usage madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues l'ordre du jour appelle
les questions d'actualité au
Gouvernement notre séance est
retransmise en direct sur Public Sénat
sur notre site
internet chacun observera les valeurs
qui sont pour nous importantes le
respect des uns et des autres une valeur
concrète qui le respect du temps de
parole ça vaut pour les parlementaires
comme pour les ministres la parole à
l'exception de la première ministre la
parole est à pascalizard pour le groupe
réublain monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues dans la
situation actuelle je tenais à saluer
l'initiative d'une marche contre
l'antisémitisme lancé par le président
Larcher et la présidente brun
Pivet ce fut je le crois nous le croyons
un bel événement de cohésion nationale
auquel comme d'autres j'ai regretté
l'absence du président Macron l'attaque
du Hamas survenue le 7 octobre 2023 sur
le sol israélien a frappé le monde
d'effroid plus de 2000 terroristes
islamistes ont assassiné méthodiquement
1200 personnes capturé 240 otages 40 de
nos compatriotes sont morts sont portés
disparus dont certains sont autage dans
ce contexte dramatique la sinueuse
stratégie française déroute les Français
comme nos partenaires internationaux
après avoir rappelé la ligne de la
France il semble que le chef de l'État a
enchaîné les initiatives controversées
aujourd'hui c'est autour d'un éventuel
cessellefeu qui pourrait être mis à
profit par les terroristes que les
incompréhensions se cristallisent nos
diplomates les plus chevrenés expriment
des doutes et des inquiétude même une
certaine presse qui vous est
habituellement favorable exprime ses
graves réserves madame la ministre en
fait ma question est simple quelle est
la cohérence de tout cela et quelle
initiative d'enverdure concertée et
expliquer la France compte-elle enfin
promouvoir pour sortir de cette
crise répond la parole est au ministre
délégué en charge du commerce extérieur
des Français de l'étranger Monsieur
Olivier
bestch merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Aliza
la position de la France est claire
depuis le 7 octobre depuis le 7 octobre
c'est-à-dire l'attaque du groupe
terroriste Hamas sur Israël nous avons
évidemment condamné cette attaque et
affirmé le droit d'Israël à se défendre
légitimement dans le cadre du respect du
droit international et du droit
humanitaire nous avons demandé la
libération immédiate et sans condition
de l'ensemble des otages nous n'avons
jamais fait l'assimilation entre le
Hamas et le peuple palestinien nous
avons organisé ici même à Paris une
conférence humanitaire pour Gaza réunie
1 milliard d'euros pour l'aide
humanitaire et demander à ce que cette a
humanitaire puisse être acheminé
directement à Gaza nous mettons tout en
œuvre sur un plan sécuritaire pour
éviter que la région ne s'embrase avec
deux visites de la ministre de l'Europe
et des Affaires étrangères Madame
Catherine Colona dont j'excuse
aujourd'hui l'absence puisqu'elle
accompagne le président de la République
dans sa visite d'État en Suisse le
ministre des Armées Sébastien Lecornu
est en ce moment même également dans les
pays du golf pour travailler à cette
action diplomatique et éviter une
extension du conflit nous travaillons
également sur le plan humanitaire je
l'ai dit pour faire en sorte que cette
aide soit acheminée à Gaza et enfin nous
travaillons sur le plan politique pour
faire en sorte que lorsque la trêve
humanitaire que nous demandons aura
débouché sur un cess de feu nous
puissions reprendre un processus
politique qui permettent la coexistence
du peuple palestinien et de l'État
d'Israël la solution à deux États qui
est la seule qui permette à de peuples
de vivre en paix et en sécurité
l'un à côté de l'autre
merci Monsieur le Ministre la diplomatie
gaulienne c'est d'être en capacité de
parler à tout le monde et non pas de
dire à chacun ce qu'il a envie
d'entendre entre cavalier seul et leçon
de morale nous appliquons les mêmes
recettes qui nous ont malheureusement
déjà tant des servis dans l'Union
européenne et à l'internationale
dernièrement les relations se sont
tendues avec les Israéliens en raison de
déclarations ambigues du chef de l'État
quant aux pays arabes ils n'ont fait que
de nous recevoir poliment je précise ce
n'est pas notre outil diplomatique qui
est en cause mais je le crois
profondément le pilotage politique au
plus haut niveau
[Musique]
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Bernard pour le groupe du Rassemblement
des démocrates progressistes et
indépendant merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et messieurs les ministres mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre de l'économie hier
matin monsieur le ministre vous avez
annoncé un accord entre l'État et EDF
sur le prix de l'électricité nucléaire
un accord d'une importance majeur pour
nos concitoyens mais aussi pour nos
entreprises et nos collectivités un
accord où EDF s'engage à vendre son
électricité nucléire à un prix évalué à
70 € le mgawh en moyenne après 1 an de
négociation ition intense et après avoir
obtenu gain de cause au niveau européen
sur la décorrélation du coût de
l'électricité de celui des énergies
fossile notamment du gaz la France
reprend enfin le contrôle sur les prix
de l'électricité de plus alors que la
régulation actuelle ne pait que sur
un/ers de la production ce nouvel accord
porte sur l'intégralité de l'électricité
produite ceci permet à F de gagner en
visibilité ce qui est essentiel pour un
acteur industriel cela l'IT également
pour nos citoyens et nos collectivités
par ailleurs je me réjouis que le tarif
réglementé de vente soit préservé pour
les ménages et les TPE tout comme je le
soulligne avec satisfaction le fait
qu'il soit simplifié en supprimant le
seuil fixé à 36 kV AMP si les raisons
d'applaudir une telle entente sont
nombreuses force est de constater que
nous devons apporter des précisions aux
consommateurs par conséquent monsieur le
ministre quel sera l'impact de cet
accord sur la facture de nos con
citoyens et des entreprises en 2025
enfin si ce pacte permettra de préserver
la situation financière d'df comment
s'appliquera-t-il aux opérateurs
alternatifs je vous remercie pour vous
répondre à la parole est au ministre de
l'Économie et finances et de la
souveraineté industrielle Monsieur le
Maire vous avez la parole monsieur le
ministre merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur le Sénateur Bui je je
suis heureux de vous retrouver parce que
nous avons passé près de 2 heures
ensemble à la commission des affaires
économiques hier au
Sénat commission particulièrement
constructive et efficace je tiens à le
dire je ne suis jamais aussi heureux que
lorsque je suis au Sénat vous le
voyez cet accord vous l'avez
parfaitement dit monsieur le sénateur
c'est un accord stratégique pour la
nation française d'abord il a été permis
je rends hommage au travail qui été fait
par agès Pier runaché par l'accord
trouvé par la ministre de l'énergie en
Europe qui nous permet de découpler
définitivement les prix de l'électricité
en France des prix du gaz deuxème
remarque cet accord ne s'applique qu'à
partir du 1er janvier 2026 donc en 2025
la situation reste inchangée pour les
ménages comme pour les entreprises trème
élément que vous avez souligné qui est
absolument décisif l'immense intérêt de
cet accord c'est qu'il s'applique sur
100 % la production électrique nucléaire
de DF donc quand j'entends les
comparaisons ce matin à la radio ou à la
télévision entre 42 € le MWh aujourd'hui
et demain 70 € mgaw je comprends
l'inquiétude des entrepreneurs des
industriels des bénages qui disent mais
ma facture va augmenter de plus de 60 %
sauf que les 42 € le mgawh pent sur
1/ers de la production les 70 € en
moyenne sur 100 % de la production quand
vous allez à la boulangerie quand vous
achetez tout le gâteau c'est plus cher
qu'une seule part du gâteau cet accord
il permet de garantir par conséquent la
compétitivité de nos entreprises
industrielles c'était l'objectif numéro
1 nous aurons nous aurons un des prix
mais pour une fois que je vous vois j'en
profite pour parler avec
amitié cet accord il garantit la
compétitivité de nos entreprises
industrielles avec un des prix les plus
compétitifs de tous les pays européens
c'était notre priorité absolu en 2uxème
lieu il garantit la stabilité au ménag
c'était notre deuxème priorité il n'y
aura pas de ressaut entre fin 25 et
début 2026 puisque les prix seront
étalés dans le temps nous ne voulons pas
que les ménages connaissent à nouveau
l'explosion des prix qu'ils ont connu
pendant la crise énergétique enfin en
3oème lieu le garantie de rentabilité de
DF c'est pas parce que DF est à 100 %
publ qu'elle doit perdre de l'argent
enfin vous l'avez dit c'était réclamé
par les sénateurs désormais les tarifs
régulés s'appliqueront à toutes les TPE
quel que soit leur puissance même si
elles sont au-dessus de 36 kV ampè
c'était une demande des sénateurs nous y
avons donc
répondu monsieur
buis la parole est à notre collègue
Pierre Jean Roch pour le groupe Les
Indépendants République et
territoire monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
la France entière est traumatisée par la
multiplication des actes antisémites
dans notre pays ils appelle une
condamnation unanime je profite
d'ailleurs de mon intervention pour vous
remercier monsieur le Président ainsi
que madame la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale d'avoir organisé cette marche
contre l'antisémitisme et pour la
République qui fut un réel succès
bravo
nous ne devons pas tolérer le cancer de
la haine au sein de notre nation ce
cancer n'est hélas pas nouveau nous le
pensions en rémission mais les
événements du Proche Orient le mois
dernier ont entraîné une forte
résurgence de ces actes monsieur le
ministre pouvez-vous nous donner le
bilan exact de ces agressions combien
ont fait l'objet de poursuite et de
condamnation les Français ont besoin de
savoir ils attendent de la fermeté dans
la réponse
judiciaire conjointement par des
incitations à la relayé sur les réseaux
sociaux des puissances étrangères
tentent de déstabiliser notre pays
l'affaire des couples moldaves peignant
des étoiles de David sur des immeubles
en est la dernière illustration monsieur
le ministre pouvez-vous nous dire
pourquoi les intéressés n'ont-ils pas
fait l'objet de poursuite de poursuite
pénale pourquoi ont-ils simplement été
expulsés que savez-vous de leurs
commanditair dont la presse semble
unanime à désigner les services de
renseignement russse d'autres actions
similaires de la part de ces mêmes av
sont-elles été identifié au cours de ces
dernières années des conséquences
diplomatiques en seront-elles tirées si
cette piste est
confirmé la désinformation et les
manœuvres de la cybergerre sont en train
de tuer la démocratie nous en sommes
depuis longtemps déjà la cble tant à
l'étranger que sur notre propre sol il
nous faut répondre comment le
gouvernement lutte-t-il contre les
tentatives étrangères de désinformation
je vous
remercie pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de l'Intérieur monsieur
géraldin merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur effectivement
depuis le 7 octobre pardon mais déjà
très présent en France depuis le 1er
janvier des actes où les événements
antisémites se sont multipliés à l'heure
où je vous parle c'est 1762 événements
ou actes antisémites qui ont été
constatés par les policiers et gendarmes
extrêmement nombreux vous le savez plus
de 10000 personnes dans les 950 lieux
que les Français de confession Ju
fréquente le plus notamment les écoles
ou les synagogues qui ont donné lieu à
571 inter 571 pardon interpellation dont
130 étrangers je veux dire que sur les
130 étrangers les 45 qui étaient
étrangers en sitation irrégulière sont
tous mis dans les centres de rétention
administratif et ont on a commencé
commencé leur expulsion du territoire
national les autres se voi retirer leur
titre de séjour de façon systématique à
ma demande 8952 signalement sur Faros la
plateforme numérique du ministère de
l'Intérieur qui a donné lieu à 350
judiciarisations vous me posez par
ailleurs la la question de cette affaire
de couple moldave et je mes couplle avec
as qui serait l'auteur de ces graffiti
d'étoiles de David qui auraiit été posé
sur un certain nombre de sites de
maisons d'appartements où des Français
de confession juives habiteraient les
deux couples ont quitté le territoire
national le premier a été interpellé et
expulsé en effet après des
interrogatoires et puis nous avons des
éléments extrêmement précis qui nous
amène à penser qu'en effet un
commanditaire étranger est en
responsabilité dans cette situation une
affaire une information judiciaire a été
ouverte ce ce que je peux vous dire donc
il y a donc des poursuites pénales c'est
qu'il s'agit du commanditaire qui serait
en effet étranger ou qu'il s'agisse de
ces personnes qui venaient d'arriver sur
le territoire national qui ont été
expulsé du territoire national les
services d'enquête confiés par les jug
inststruction sera un service d'enquête
spécialisé qui je crois répond en partie
à votre interrogation sur les ingérences
étrangères et sur les que l'État peut
avoir je veux dire par ailleurs qu'il y
a d'autres graffiti des étoiles de David
ou des croixgamés qui sont mis partout
sur le territoire national qui ne sont
pas l'auteur eux de couple Bulgar ou
d'ingérance étrangère supposé mais bien
d'antisémite organisés qui sont
interpellés et bien sûr déféré devant
toutes les décisions prises par le
parquet monsieur
Rochet la parole est notre collègue
Michel Massier pour le gros du
Rassemblement démocratique et social
européen la
parole euh monsieur le Président Madame
le première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à madame
la ministre Dominique fort vendredi
dernier vous étiz avec Madame le Premier
ministre aux assis des département de
France vous avez tenté les rassurer tant
sur leur moyens que sur leur avenir
institutionnel notamment troublé par la
nouvelle émission Verz force de
constater que l'effort consenti par
votre gouvernement ne répond pas
totalement au besoins exprimés par le
département qui à la défaveur d'un
terrible effet ciseau traverse une très
grave crise financière lié à deux points
la contraction des frais de notaire donc
les DMTO et à l'augmentation des
dépenses
sociales vous avez rappelé le rôle
indispensable des départements il s'agit
aujourd'hui de les soutenir pour
infin vous le savez maintenir la
démocratie locale et leur
investissement dans le cas contraire
vous risqueriez de mettre à mal toute
l'édifice solidaire de notre
décentralisation je pense bien sûr aux
éepad aux 10 aux PMI mais également au
servicees de soins en domicile au
collège tant de services indispensables
à notre quotidien dans nos
territoires fraîchement élu du lotégaron
et ancien vice-président de ce
département je demeure attaché à cette
collectivité de proximité qui supplit
des services de l'État notamment dans
les territoires ruraux ainsi madame la
ministre comptez-vous intégrer dans
l'examen des projets de loi en cours des
mesures plus que significatives pour
permettre au départements de retrouver
leur autonomie financière et assurer
sereinement leur mission de
solidarité pour vous répondre la parole
est à la ministre déléguée en charge des
collectivités
territoriales merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs monsieur le sénateur Michel
massé vous faites référence à
l'interprétation du président François
sauvadé euh cette interpellation à
destination de la première ministre
vendredi dernier en clôture du congrès
annuel de l'Association des départements
de France cette interpellation traduit
une inquiétude de disparition de
l'échelon départemental inquiétude que
je dois vous avouer je perçois aussi le
président de la
République s'interroge tout simplement
sur le mil le millefeuille territorial
et a engagé une réflexion sur notre
organisation territoriale il a aussi
conf une mission à Eric ver une mission
parlementaire ces travaux tiendront
compte de l'importance de l'échelon
départementale à une époque où nos
concitoyens réclament de la proximité en
toute chose proximité dans l'état et
notre gouvernement s'est montré je le
pense que nous avons le souci de
maintenir cette proximité de la recréer
là où elle n'existe pas suffisamment où
elle n'existe plus sur bien des sujets
aménagement du territoire politique
sociale transition écologique aussi
service public la maille départementale
est une maille pertinente qui permet de
travailler à l'échelle de territoire
cohérent tout en gardant cette capacité
d'action de proximité à laquelle nous
sommes extrêmement attachés notre
réflexion se fera donc à l'on du rôle
essentiel des départements dans
l'actuelle organisation territoriale
j'en suis convaincu comme la première
ministre qui sait apprécié la juste
contribution des départements à la
vitalité des territoires et qui le leur
a dit vendredi dernier je veux quand
même rappeler avant de conclure le
soutien financier que le gouvernement et
les moyens accord au département que le
gouvernement a débloqué 150 millions
d'euros pour l'autonomie 100 millions
d'euros pour répondre à la problématique
des mineurs non accompagnés et 100
millions d'euros pour les départements
en situation de fragilité oui monsieur
le sénateur nous veillons sur nos
départements je vous
remercie les départements madame la
ministre vous le savez sont Desle
activité essentielle pour l'équilibre
dans nos territoire premier financeur de
la solidarité premier aménageur ils sont
aujourd'hui les acteurs publics locaux
reconnus de l'égalité et du maintien des
services publics rétablir l'autonomie
financière des département est un enjeu
qui dépasse le seuil le seul échalon
départemental j'espère j'espère don
votre soutien plein et entier pour le
maintien des départements au sein de
l'architecture territoriale et de figer
nos territoires
actuels la parole est à notre collègue
Bernard jaumier pour le groupe
socialiste écologiste et
[Applaudissements]
républicain merci monsieur le président
madame la Première ministre mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues nous examinons cette semaine
au Sénat le budget de la Sécurité
sociale présenté par le
gouvernement vous nous présentez un
budget qui est en déficit de 8 milliards
pour 2023 qui le sera de 11 en 2024 et
de 17 en
2027 c'est une trajectoire qui est
totalement inédite alors que la crise
sanitaires et ses effets sont derrière
nous alors ma question elle est très
simple pourquoi n'êtes-vous pas capable
de ramener les finances sociales à
l'équilibre avez-vous baissé les bras
avez-vous
renoncé répondre la parole est au
ministre de la santé et de la
prévention
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs monsieur le
sénateur le le Gouvernement présente en
effet un projet de loi financement de la
sécurité sociale qui ramène le déficit
de la branche maladie qui était de 22
milliards l'an dernier à 8,8 milliards
d'euros sur un total de 255 milliards
d'euros de dépenses vos collègues qui
siègent à la commission des finances
serait sans doute heureux de connaître
ce ratio de de déficit euh mais vous
avez raison un déficit plus lourd dans
la durée n'est pas soutenable il n'est
pas soutenable parce que l'assurance
maladie n'appartient pas à l'état elle
appartient aux assurés elle a elle est
gérée par les partenaires sociaux sous
le et le gouvernement n''est que le que
le garant c'est pourquoi dans ce projet
de loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale nous avançons et je l'ai formulé
dans la discussion générale sur une
ligne de crête qui quelquefois vous
conduit du reste à des critiques des
deux côtés de cette ligne de crête fait
à la fois permettre et mobiliser les
moyens notamment renforcer les moyens
dans le champ de la prévention assurer
l'augmentation des rémunérations des
soignants financer le Ségure de la santé
mais de l'autre côté ralentir la
dynamique de certaines dépenses
notamment les dépenses de soins de ville
notamment les dépenses de médicaments
qui ont augmenté l'an dernier de 7 % et
que nous devons absolument ralentir à
l'heure où je vous parle monsieur le
sénateur les discussions entre les
médecin et l'assurance maladie sont en
train de reprendre un des axes majeurs
qui réconcilie selon moi les objectifs
de santé publique et les objectifs de
finances publiques c'est celui du
travail sur lequel tous les syndicats de
médecins sont prêts à s'engager quel que
soit leur composition ou leur sociologie
c'est celui de la pertinence des soins
et c'est aussi et c'est très important
parce que la pertinence c'est là où se
rejoint la santé publique et la maîtrise
de nos dépenses et par ailleurs la
prévention doit sans doute aujourd'hui
faire l'objet d'une réflexion plus large
sur son financement puisque quand nous
finançons nous achetons des vaccins HPV
pour cette année c'est pour éviter des
cancers dans 30 ans donc je l'ai dit
nous sommes prêts aussi à ouvrir ce
débat sur le financement de la
prévention merci Monsieur le
cénateur euh merci monsieur le ministre
pour votre réponse mais j'ai interrogé
le gouvernement sur le déficit de la
Sécurité sociale et vous m'avez répondu
sur le déficit du budget santé h une
toute petite partie de la réponse je
n'ai entendu dans vos propos aucune
volonté voilà aucune forte dans une
trajectoire de retour à l'équilibre rien
donc en 2027 quand le chef de l'État
finira son deuxème mandat il laissera
des finances sociales plus dégradées
qu'à son arrivée et largement on pourra
accepter ces déficites parlons du budget
santé si les indicateurs de santé du
pays s'amélioraient mais nous reculons
de la 6e à la la 13e place en terme
d'espérance de vie à la naissance et la
mortalité infantile progresse nous
pourrions accepter des déficits si
l'hôpital allait mieux qu'il y a 5 ou 6
ans mais l'hôpital se dégrade les
personnels s'en vont et l'offre de soins
se contracte nous pourrions accepter des
déficit si nos concitoyens sur tout le
territoire avaient accès aux soins de
proximité avaient accès à un médecin
généraliste mais les déserts médicaux se
répandent et les pénuries s'accroissent
vous êtes donc en échec ce sont des
vagues de mauvais résultats dans un
océan de déficit monsieur le ministre
votre gouvernement gère mal la sécurité
sociale la
parole notre collègue
kyopoli pour le groupe communiste
républicain citoyen
écologiste monsieur le ministre le
ptecalé connaî depuis 2 semaines le les
inondations les plus catastrophiques du
siècle plus d'un tiers des communes
touchées habitation entreprise
exploitation agricole ou bâtiments
publics je tiens à saluer l'immense
courant de solidarité de tout le pays
qui apporte un peu de chaleur aux
populations dans ce moment dramatique la
très forte implication des élus locaux
en particulier des Maes au côté des
sinistrés jour et nuit ses mes si
souvent décriés parfois découragés font
la démonstration une fois de plus de
leur dévouement ils souhait une
simplification des procédures pour leur
permettre d'intervenir sur l'entretien
démaré défaussé entre autres merci à
tous ces volontaires anonymes
association pompiers sécurité civile
agents communaux et services de l'État
qui font un travail admirable la visite
du président de la République nous donne
l'espoir d'une application durable de
l'état où les premiers actes attendus
par la population pour résoudre les
problèmes ont été posés les 50 milliards
d'euros d' d'urgence sont un premier pas
mais d'évidence nonobstant la la
participation des assurances les
investissements nécessaires pour
reconstruire puis prévenir de telles
catastrophes vont exploser cette
enveloppe c'est d'un véritable plan
marchant pour le pas de calé monsieur le
ministre dont nous avons besoin
l'immensité des problèmes à résoudre le
relogement de nos populations dans le
désespoir ne doivent pas nous exonérer
de réfléchir déjà aux mesures
structurelles à prendre des mesures
techniques bassin de rétention d'eau
entretien des écluses et des pompes et
des voitringues et cetera et cetera
offront rapidement des perspectives
posons les premiers actes faute de quoi
les entreprises vont partir les
agriculteurs jeter l'éponge et la
désespérance s'ancré dans la population
pouvez-vous monsieur le ministre nous
éclairer sur la réflexion de l'État et
la réponse qu'il entend apportter aux
propositions des présidents de la région
des haut-- Fran et aux présidents du
département pasal je vous remercie pour
répondre la parole ministre de
[Applaudissements]
l'Intérieur merci monsieur le Président
Madame la la sénatrice avec Christophe
Béchu dès le premier jour dans votre
département dans notre région puis le
président de la République avec
Christophe Béchu et le ministre de
l'Agriculture nous sommes évidemment au
côté des habitants du pcalis et du Nord
puisque le Nord a été aussi touché
notamment dans sa côté flendre
singulièrement évidemment devant des
inondations qui sont extrêmement
impressionnantes et qui font suite à une
tempête celle qui a touché l'ouest de la
France si jeux dire les les personnes du
pas decalé ont connu à la fois la
tempête avec des submersions et puis ces
inondations qui continuent et qui sont
encore extrêmement importante sur le sur
le terrain je voudrais d'abord remercier
les services de secours quel qu'ils soit
les policiers les gendarmes la
protection civile la sécurité civile
6000 personnes ont été évacuées et des
incidents qui sont extrêmement graves de
façon matérielle mais qui heureusement
ne l'ont pas été sur les questions
personnelles puisque je crois que le
travail très important qu'on fait
notamment les sapurs pompiers plus de
1000 Sapur pompiers dont la moitié sont
venus soit des militaires du ministère
de l'intérieur soit des autres
départements de France ont montré la
solidarité que que vous évoquez nous
avons réuni avec le ministre en charge
de la transition écologique dès hier la
réforme la commission catastrophe
naturelle puisque nous avons 191
communes qui ce matin au Journal
officiel dans votre département ont été
reconnu en catastrophe naturelle une
vingtaine dans le Nord et 30 encore
communes qui ne sont pas concerné mais
qui doivent déposer leur dossier on sait
que c'est toujours difficile il y aura
donc une session de rattrapage bien
évidemment la prochaine semaine le
président de la République a annoncé un
sous-préfet pour le pas decalé et pour
le nord pour organiser en effet cette
simplification je viendrai samedi dans
votre département samedi après-midi de
nouveau pour pouvoir installer ce
sous-préfet réunir les élus et
évidemment être à l'écoute pour
notamment demander aux assureurs de
remplir leurs tâches là où l'État a fait
la la sienne notamment sur ce qui
concerne les catastrophes naturelles je
laisserai le ministre en charge de la
transition écologique il y a d'autres
questions répondre sur l'écurage et sur
les dotations d'investissements qui
peuvent concerner les
communes la parole est à notre collègue
Amel gaker pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste vous avez la
parole monsieur le Président Mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse au
ministre de la transition écologique et
de la cohésion des
territoires depuis une quinzaine de
jours le département du pas de calé j'en
parle à nouveau sujet qui vient d'être
évoqué subit des inondations
exceptionnelles alors même qu'il avait
été fragilisé par la tempête siarrant
quelques jours auparavant ce sont près
de 250 communes impactées par des
épisodes de pluie torrentiel de cru et
d'inondation sans précédent aussi bien
en terme de durée que d'intensité en
terme de précipitation il est tombé en
un mois ce qui tombe habituellement en 6
mois les dernières annonces du
gouvernement vont dans le bon sens
l'état de catastrophe naturelle prononcé
pour 244 communes du nord et du pas
decalais j'en profite pour ajouter que
d'autres départements sont touchés dans
les eut de France mais pas que ainsi
donc un fond de soutien de 50 millions
d'euros à destination des collectivités
bien sûr une première enveloppe
bienvenue mais bien évidemment
insuffisante au regard des dégâts
monsieur le ministre la visite du
président de la République hier à
SaintOmer a révélé des besoins criants
des sinistrés et des communes pour faire
face à cette catastrophe des besoins
pour gérer l'urgence mais également des
besoins en matière de prévention les
attentes sont de tout ordre financier
juridique opérationnel financièrement
d'abord il est impossible aujourd'hui
d'avancer un chiffrage des dégâts des
désordres pour les habitants mais
également pour nos commerçants artisans
agriculteurs entrepreneurs par contre il
est indispensable ble de veiller à
simplifier à accélérer les procédures
administratives pour permettre à chacun
de reprendre une vie normal
juridiquement ensuite les élus dont je
salue l'investissement entier auprès de
leurs administration vous demande encore
de leurs administré pardon vous demande
encore de la souplesse dans l'exercice
de leurs compétences faciliter
l'entretien des cours d'eau par exemple
des faussés ils sont encadrés par trop
de normes et de contraintes qui tiennent
essentiellement des envonn exive
monsieur le ministre vous le savez avec
le réchauffement climatique ce risque
d'événement risque de se multiplier les
séqu sont matériel mais également
psychologi la confiance la question
pardon est de savoir aujourd'hui comment
vous allez redonner confiance à nos
concitoyens je vous
remercie rép la parole minist de la
transition écologique la cohésion des
territoire monsieur le
président mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs madame la sénatrice gaker vous
l'avez dit pas plus tard qu'hier vous
étiez présente pour la visite du
président de la République quand avec
Olivier Grégoire avec Marc fenau nous
avons été à la rencontre des des
sinistrés des communes concerné et ça
faisait suite à la visite que Gérald
haranin leur avait rendu dès la semaine
dernière d'abord aujourd'hui même une
proposition de simplification sur les
curages des rivières a été transmis au
Conseil d'État ce sujet il ne concerne
pas que le nord et les haut de France il
est attendu dans divers territoires vous
vous doutez bien que si on l'a transmis
dès aujourd'hui c'est qu'on y
travaillait depuis un certain temps déjà
nous étions arrivés à une copie
permettant de concilier ces impératifs
écologiques et ces besoins de prévention
que vous évoquez je veux rendre justice
madame la sénatrice d'abord aux
institutions et aux élus locaux de ce
territoire qui ont par les travaux
qu'ils ont conduit fait alors que nous
avons vous l'avez dit des niveaux
historiques de cru sur les rivières de
ce territoire nous n'avons pas eu autant
de sinistrés qu'il y a 20 ans parce que
les Diges les dispositifs de bassin le
suivi qui ont eu lieu dans tous les
divers territoires ont permis de porter
leurs fruits en revanche on doit trouver
un meilleur équilibre entre la poursuite
d'un principe de précaution qui a permis
de montrer ces résultats et le fait de
pas aller trop loin dans des exigences
qui finissent par heurter le bon sens et
par limiter la capacité d'intervenir au
milieu de tout ça il y a l'urgence 50
millions d'euros annoncés qui n
permettre et c'est un début
d'accompagner les collectivités pour les
infrastructures pour les ouvrages d'art
de manière sans attendre à pouvoir les
accompagner le travail de consolidation
des dégâts la reconnaissance de
catastrophes naturelles déclaré hier par
le ministre de l'Intérieur et un travail
qui va se poursuivre quand l'eau va
véritablement baisser ce qu'on espère
pour le début de la semaine prochaine
pour tirer toutes les conséquences en
terme de prévention et en terme de suivi
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Daniel salmon pour le groupe écologiste
solidarité et territoire
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues demain
jeudi 16 novembre les États-membres de
l'Union européenne sont appelés à voter
sur la réautorisation pour 10 ans du
glyphosate ce vote dans lequel la France
aura un rôle déterminant à une
importance cruciale alors que l'épreuve
s'accumule sur les dangers pour la santé
et l'environnement de cette molécule
vous le savez le glyphosate est classé
comme cancérogène probable depuis 2015
par le Centre international de ch cher
sur le cancer l'inerme en 2021 insistait
quant à lui sur son potentiel comme
perturbateur endocrinien et son lien
avec des maladiie neurodégénérativ ces
jours derniers l'fsa a reconnu des
défaillances elle-même dans ses
méthodologies d'évaluation du risque si
la France s'abstient à nouveau demain
sur le glyphosate elle aura une lourde
responsabilité pourtant on s'en souvient
le président de la République annoncé en
2017 une sortie de son usage en France
sous 3 ans souhaitant entraîner l'Europe
entière derrière lui aujourd'hui on
constate un abandon de tout leadership
sur la question la France a quitté le
wagon de tête pour être en queue de
train avec un discours à géométrie
variable un jour le prétexte national
pour l'inaction et la distorsion de
concurrence avec nos voisins et
aujourd'hui vous ne montrez aucune
ambition au niveau de l'Union européenne
alors que d'autres États-membres ont
pris des positions bien plus courageuses
aussi Monsieur le Ministre la France
votera-t-elle contre la réautorisation
du glyphosate êtes-vous prêt à jouer
votre pour son interdiction rapide au
niveau
européen répondre la parole ministre
l'agriculture de la souveré alimentaire
Monsieur Merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur salmon comme vous
le savez demain c'est la commission
d'appel au fond de du sujet sur la
réhomologation du glyphosate la position
de la France sur ce sujet là dans le
cadre de la perspective de homologation
est la même depuis le début nous ntions
pas d'accord et nous ne sommes pas
d'accord avec la position de la
Commission telle qu'elle est formulée
qui était une position en terme de durée
et en terme d'usage qui resppondz pas à
la ligne que la France a choisi et
permettez-moi de vous le dire j'en suis
désolé que la France a plutôt un
leadership puisque c'est le seul pays
d'Europe et du monde qui a pris des des
mesures d'ors et déjà de restriction
d'un certain nombre d'usages et les
résultats pardon sont au rendez-vous
puisqu'on a réduit les usages de 27 à 30
% après nous sommes dans un cadre
européen il faut reconnaître monsieur
salmon parce qu'il y a aussi des
principes de réalité qui s'imposent il y
a des usages pour lequels nous sommes
aujourd'hui en impasse je pense à
l'agriculture de conservation des sols
j'imagine que vous la défendez
puisqu'elle permet d'améliorer la
qualité des sols d'améliorer la
productivité et de stocker plus de
carbone aujourd'hui à date au moment où
je vous parle il n'y a pas d'alternative
crédiible et donc la position de la
France la position de la France elle est
simple partout où on peut réduire les
les usages conformément à la trajectoire
que nous nous sommes donnés nous le
faisons et là où il y a des impasses on
assume aussi les positions qui sont les
nôtres donc on continuera à défendre au
niveau européen la volonté de réduire
l'usage du glyphosate et en même temps
de prendre acte des solutions d'impasse
dans lesquelles nous nous trouvons et
puis enfin monsieur le sénateur salmon
les décisions qui sont sont prises et
les propositions de la Commission
européenne elles sont faites et sont
basées sur les préconisations de l'fsa
lesquels travaux de l'EFSA ont été aussi
alimentés par l'an alors on peut pas
avoir la science à géométrie variable en
fonction des convictions c'est l'fsa et
l'an qui disent un certain nombre
d'éléments sur le glyphosate écoutez
l'an et mais écutezle toujours et pas
selon vos convictions ça sera mieux pour
tout le
[Applaudissements]
monde monsieur le ministre vous le savez
parfaitement fabrique du doute
fonctionne à plein régime aujourd'hui
avec des pseudo études scientifiques
payé par les grands groupes hier l'
miante le fossile le tabac aujourd'hui
les pesticides personne n'est dupe il
faut prendre vos responsabilités nous
avons une chance demain de remettre la
France à sa place dans le leadership ne
la gâchez pas ne faites pas en sorte que
demain nous ayons honte de la position
de la France le glyphosate c'est avéré
est un poison des métaanalyses le
prouvent tous les jours ce ne sont pas
des petites études faites par les grands
groupes la parole est au président
Jean-François rappin pour le groupe les
République vous avez la parole monsieur
le Président Monsieur le président
monsieur le ministre mes chers collègues
tir groupé du pas decalé bien sûr le
rouge et l'orange ces deux couleurs sont
désormais familières mais si
angoissantes pour les habitants du pas
de-Calais mes premiers mots iront donc
vers les sinistrés des deux tempêtes et
des inondations qui se prolongent depuis
3 semaines
je pense aux habitants sinistrés bien
trop nombreux ils n'ont plus de maison
ils n'ont plus de vêtements ni de
chaussures et leur regard est vide car
désespéré tout comme leur mère qui
malgré leur courage sont épuisé et à
bout de solution je pense au sinistrés
agricoles qui n'ont plus de champs à
semer plus de bêtes à faire pâurer plus
de légumes à récolter je pense au
sinistrés économiqu qui ne peuvent plus
faire fonctionner leurs entreprises ni
faire travailler leurs salariés jamais
nous n'avons connu catastrophe d'une
telle ampleur avec une étendue
géographique si importante jamais nous
n'avons autant souhaité la solidarité
locale et nationale pour venir effacer
le désespoir d'un avenir sombre encore à
découvrir au-delà de la solidarité des
collectivités locales qui est déjà
précisée et qui va s'accroître au-delà
de la solidarité nationale qui est
pleinement assurée dans l'urgence par
nos préfets et leurs services la
représentation nationale et les
collectivités attend des précisions pour
le futur de ces sinistrés nous nous
avons aussi besoin d'une solidarité
européenne comme je l'ai dit au
président de la République hier je
souhaite que l'on puisse d'ors et déjà
activer les trois mécanismes de soutien
européen le premier mécanisme qui est
celui de la protection civile de l'Union
européenne le deuxième est le fond de
solidarité de l'Union européenne qui
peut-être activé pour des catastrophes
régionales et enfin l'instrument d'aide
d'urgence j'ai deux questions
pouvez-vous nous préciser les
dispositions nationales qui seront
prises par le gouvernement et nous
préciser si l'Union europé est déjà
sollicité dans la gestion de cette
catastrophe
naturelle pour vous répondre la
[Musique]
parole Monsieur
bchu Merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les
Sénateurs oui nous avons activé les
dispositifs européens et nous allons
même un peu plus loin puisque le
président de la République a souhaité
que nous puissions faire une comparaison
entre la manière dont nos amis belges
hollandais qui sont confrontés en ce
moment même en Belgique à des
inondations du même type mobilisent
leurs mécanismes nationaux quel type
d'accompagnement budgétaire quelle
politique d'adaptation en amont je pense
que dans ce domaine y compris vous
l'avez dit parce qu'on a affaire à un
événement climatique hors norme mais que
nous avons des raisons de penser qu'il
se reproduira puisque les experts nous
disent qu'on aura des épisodes de pluie
intenses de plus en plus nombreux tout
en vivant des sécheresses estivales nous
devons regarder comment d'autres se
préparent à ce type de
dispositif activation des dispositifs
européens comparaison de ce qui se passe
et puis dans le même temps vous me
donnez l'opportunité de valoriser aussi
l'action de Marc fen avec le
déclenchement du dispositif sur les
calamités agricoles et les annonces
qu'il a fait ce matin à la fois pour les
départements qui ont été touchés par la
tempête siaran par la tempête Domingos
et par les inondations puisque ce sont
80 millions d'euros qui vont être
débloqués pour là aussi accompagner et
vérifier que les agriculteurs qui sont
concernés et je joins ceux qui
exploitent des fraises à plouastel à
ceux que vous évoquez pour la betterave
ou pour l'élevage qui se retrouvent dans
le dénouement que vous décrivez si bien
nous sommes déterminés à utiliser tous
les leviers nationaux et européens pour
accompagner les sinistrés de ces
territoire il y a une chose qu'on peut
pas faire et vous venez de le faire avec
beaucoup de justesse monsieur le
sénateur c'est qu'au-delà des chiffres
au-delà des mécanismes au-delà des
reconnaissances au-delà des labels que
nous ayons collectivement une pensée et
un hommage pour les élus pour les
bénévoles pour les associations pour les
employés municipaux qui sur le terrain
depuis des jours et des jours ne compent
ni leurs heur ni leur peine merci
d'avoir pensé à les citer ils sont au
cœur de nos pensées et je pense que nous
pouvons collectivement au-delà des
sinistrés les applaudir pour ce qu'ils
font depuis le 6
novembre RA
monsieur le ministre je me tiens à votre
disposition et celle du gouvernement
avec les deux présidentses de région et
du département pour rencontrer la
Commission européenne parce que
finalement vous m'avez répondu sur les
les plans à mettre en place mais pas
forcément sur les financements et je
pense qu'il faut être précis là-dessus
deuxièmement je pense monsieur le
ministre preuve est faite et vous l'avez
entendu hier de tous les maires qu'il
faudra reparler de curage de faocardage
de fcinage de débroussaillage de bassins
de rétention pour nos cours d'eau à
l'écoute des élus locaux plutôt que de
dépenser trop d'argent en études qui
sont incessantes usantes traînantes et
parfois inutil
la parole est à notre collègue Corine
Ferret pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste et
républain merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre il y a moins d'un
mois plus d'un millier d'êes soignants
d'infirmiers de sages-femmes et de
médecins dénoncés dans une tribune
publiée dans le journal Le Monde les je
cite dilemme éthique intenable auquel
ils sont confrontés faute de lit et de
personnel dans nos hôpitaux partout dans
mon département le Calvados comme
ailleurs les soignants alertent sur la
dégradation sans fin de leur condition
de travail ils indiquent ne pas avoir
choisi de travailler à l'hôpital pour
être contraint de trier les patients ou
d'être maltraitant il y a quelques mois
le service statistique du ministère de
la Santé indiquait que plus de 21000 lit
avaient été supprimés entre 2017 et fin
2021 l'essentiel du premier quinquen
d'Emmanuel Macron donc dans 173 villes
163 villes pardon de France les urgences
ont été ponctuellement fermées cet été
en raison de la démission de personnel
aujourd'hui encore il y a dans certains
établissements 30 % de lit fermés et
parfois même ce sont des services entier
pas une semaine ne se passe sans que
l'état de délabrement du secteur de la
psychiatrie celui de la pédiatrie
victime d'un abandbon de l'État ne fasse
la une sans parler de toutes ces
maternités que vous avez laissé se
dégrader au point que plus personne ne
veut y travailler alors Monsieur le
Ministre sortez des logiques comptables
technocratiques allez-vous enfin écouter
les professionnels de terrain garantir
un nombre maximal de patients par
soignant comme le Sénat l'a voté et
donner à l'hôpital public les moyens de
prendre correctement en charge les
patients pour vous répondre la parole
est au ministre de la Santé
monsieurous monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
madame la
sénatrice l'hôpital est singulièrement
l'hôpital public est dans une situation
difficile il connaît une crise il
connaît une crise qui a des racines
profondes et qui font écho en partie à
la question que votre collègue Bernard
jaumier posait tout à l'heure l'avantage
d'avoir un peu d'expérience c'est de
pouvoir aussi revenir sur certaines de
ses propres erreurs en 2017 le la
sécurité sociale la branche maladie
était à l'équilibre en effet mais sans
doute AV à l'hôpital avaitt-il été la
variable d'ajustement de ces dépenses et
sans doute que on était allé trop loin
dans la régulation financière à cette
période-là l'hôpital il connait une
triple crise une crise qui est issue de
la de la situation sanitaire et du covid
une crise des vocations et une crise qui
est liée plus ponctuellement à
l'inflation sur ces trois crises l'État
n'a jamais euh tourneré les yeux n'a
jamais été dans une situation de dénis
l'augmentation des rémun gération des
soignants elle n'a jamais été aussi
forte depuis 30 ans le segéure
investissement il va apporter 19
milliards d'euros même si évidemment ces
19 milliards d'euros sont érodés par
l'inflation dans les établissements de
santé nous sommes aussi nous avons été
aussi au rendez-vous pour la crise covid
avec le système de la garantie de
financement et madame la sénatrice si je
peux partager une partie de vos
évidemment une partie de vos constats je
j'aurais tendance à à à à me référer à
un un grand un grand
parlementaire qui avait l'habitude de me
dire que sur tous les samedis matins
devant euh dans sur le marché de sa
commune sa commune s'était rembouillée
il y avait le collectif de défense de
l'hôpital qui indiquait que l'hôpital
était à l'agonie que les soignants
allaient tous disparaître et bien
écoutez expliquez-moi après comment les
patients peuvent se dire je vais aller à
la maternité de rambouiller je vais
aller aux urgences de rambouiller je
vais va aller faire ma chirurgie à
rambouiller à force de dire que
l'hôpital est à l'agonie malheureusement
certaines certains faits sont
autoréalisateur merci alors madame Ferré
on va revenir dans le
Calvados monsieur le ministre et alors
et alors nous avons votre réponse que
vous venez de faire nous nous l'avons
déjà entendu maint fois de la part de
vos prédécesseurs mais forcé de
constater que la situation elle s'est
encore dégradée nos hôpitaux doivent
demeurer des lieux de soins sûrs et
humains et les Français comme les
soignants attendent des actes
[Applaudissements]
forts la parole est à notre collègue
Laurent Duplomb pour le groul
[Applaudissements]
républicain monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Ministre aujourd'hui il y a
deux types d'acteurs
ceux qui veulent une agriculture qui
rime avec environnement et qui croit au
progrès et ceux qui considèrent que
l'agriculture s'oppose par nature à
l'environnement et veulent l'éradiquer
je fais partie de la première la
Commission européenne du Parlement
européen en cohérence avec avec sa
doctrine décroissante fait partie de la
seconde dernière décision en date dans
le cadre de l'examen du Règlement sur
l'usage durable des pesticides dans les
zones Natura 2000 qui partai pour d'un
bon principe le Parlement veut désormais
interdire toute pratique sauf en
agriculture biologique dont on connaît
la crise du
surproduction en résumé soit les
agriculteurs se convertissent et vendent
à perte soit ils s'arrête tout de suite
autrement dit pour protéger ces zones
comme j'avais déjà prévenu il y a 2 ans
ici on accepte de rayer l'agriculture de
la carte en France Natura 2000 c'est 7
millions d'hectares dont près de 5% de
la surface en production fruitière et
70000 hectares de grande culture rien
que dans la bosse après le Green Deal
cette nouvelle décision décroissante des
gens qui préfèrent une agriculture
importée est contraire à notre
souveraineté dont votre ministère porte
le
nom je vous le dis il y a deux C ceux
qui croient en une agriculture de
progrès et ceux qui veulent éliminer
l'agriculture je fais partie du premier
camp et je m'opposerai à ce projet de
décision euréne et vous monsieur le
ministre de quelquun faites-vous
partie répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs on est toujours
commis d'office d'être dans un camp ou
dans un autre mais en tout cas je suis
dans le camp de ceux qui défendent
l'agriculture et sa souveraineté
l'agriculture française et la
souveraineté française et européenne et
vous me trouverez toujours je crois que
vous le savez monsieur le sateur dans ce
col après comment on fait une fois qu'on
a dit ça on a besoin à la fois de
trouver une trajectoire qui soit une
trajectoire économique vous avez raison
de le rappeler parce qu' pas
d'agriculture s'il y a pas de modèle
économique qui permet de rémunérer les
agriculteurs et de prendre en charge un
certain nombre de demandes qui leur sont
faites par la société ou de demandes
d'évolution deuxième élément c'est
peut-être en cela que je diffère je
crois à l'agriculture de progrès mais je
crois que le statut quo serait la pire
des choses pour l'agriculture le
dérèglement climatique les dérèglements
géopolitiques et économiques vont
imposer un certain nombre de transitions
que nous devons accag pour les
agriculteurs sinon nous ferions une
erreur tragique sur le sujet que qui
nous préoccupe tous ici au Sénat et et
ailleurs que le sujet de la permanence
de l'agriculture française 3ème élément
sur le sujet sur lequel vous commencez
votre question que est réglementation
sûr d'abord vous dites je m'oppose à une
décision la décision n'est pas prise
premier élément nous sommes dans le
cadre d'un dialogue entre le Parlement
le Conseil et la Commission qui n'a pas
du tout abouti c'est une position qui a
été exprimée par la commission
Environnement le travail se poursuit
nous suivons ça de près avec Christophe
Béchu pour qu'on puisse com combiner une
trajectoire de réduction des pesticides
qui n'a pas été déterminée par ce
gouvernement il y a 15 ans qu'elle a été
déterminée cette trajectoire de
réduction des pesticides et en même
temps quelque chose qui permet de faire
en sorte qu'on accompagne les
agriculteurs dans les transitions ça
veut dire pas d'interdiction sans
solution et donc de regarder avec
lucidité les impasses je n'ai jamais cru
que les interdictions produisaient des
solutions mais il faut chercher les
solutions donc il faut chercher les
alternatives donc il faut faire et
mettre des moyens sur la recherche enfin
on peut pas mettre en place un système
qui soit la mise sous cloche d'une
partie de nos territoirees nous
partageons ce point de vue qui fasse
qu'en gros il y a une partie des
territoires dans lequel on dise pour la
forêt ou pour l'agriculture il y a plus
de production qui soit tenable
économiquement et donc c'est là-dessus
que nous tenons les positions de la
France y compris sur les débats que vous
avez sur la réglementation sûre monsieur
duplom monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Ministre on parle des zones Natura 2000
pas d en même temps comme d'habitude
votre gouvernement laisse passer ce
genre de projet simplement pour arrondir
les angles en fin de négociation mais la
porte à la la décroissance s'ouvre
toujours un peu plus c'est toujours le
même renoncement et une fois de plus
votre gouvernement emportera l'entière
responsabilité
[Musique]
merci la parole est à Madame Annique
billon pour le groupe de l'Union
centriste merci merci monsieur le
président monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues qui voulons-nous protéger
toutes les 3 minutes un enfant est
victime de violence sexuelle chaque
année 160000 enfants sont victimes de
violences sexuelle au total 5 millions
d'adultes ont subi des violences
sexuelles dans leur enfance 92 % des
victimes ne sont pas entendues 3 % des
mises en cause pour viol sur mineurs
sont condamnés seulement qui
voulons-nous protéger c'est une
interrogation posée par le juge Édouard
Duran co-président de la civise entendu
par la délégation aux droits des femmes
la semaine dernière en 2021 le président
ident de la République a promis à toutes
les victimes qu'elle ne serait plus
jamais seule en 2021 la commission
indépendante sur l'incestes et les
violences faites aux enfants dit CIVIS a
été créé pour une durée de 3 ans ces
travaux doit s'achever ce 31 décembre
aujourd'hui elle est de devenue pardon
un espace reconstructeur qui accompagne
les victimes se pose donc la question de
son maintien en 3 ans la civise a
accompli un travail titanesque et
salvateur la Commission a recueilli
recueilli près de 30000 témoignages en 3
ans la Commission a fait des
propositions fortes avec pour seule
boussole protéger enfin les mineurs et
condamner les agresseurs dans une lettre
publiée lundi avec la présidente de la
délégation au droits des femmes
Dominique Verrien et les membres de la
délégation nous appelons le président de
la République à maintenir la civise
monsieur le ministre ma question est
simple et appelle une réponse claire
comptez-vous maintenir la civise si oui
sous quelle
forme pour vous répondre la parole à
Monsieur ver ministre délégué
porte-parole du
gouvernement merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les les sénateurs
madame la sénatrice Annique billon je
vous cherchais du regard merci soyez
assuré évidemment il y aura une suite
aux travaux de la cévise évidemment la
première ministre réunit sous son
autorité aura lieu le le 20 novembre
prochain un comité interministériel à
l'enfance qui va permettre de colliger
de compiler beaucoup de données certains
et un grand nombre d'entre eux vous
l'avez dit 30000 témoignages d'enfance
ce n'est pas rien réunis par la civise
structure que je connais bien parce que
j'étais ministre en charge de la
question de la protection de l'enfance
lorsque la civise a été créée et je
connais je reconnais le travail
fondamental de cette de cette structure
c'est une structure qui a été créée pour
3 ans vous l'avez dit dans votre
question et se pose la question de ce
qu'il va advenir maintenant de quels
outils avons-nous besoin de quel type de
commission faut-il aller vers une forme
de C vis 2 faut-il revoir ou amplifier
les choses soyez assuré puisque vous
l'avez dit vous-même c'est l'engagement
c'est la grande cause du président de la
République c'est l'engagement de ce
gouvernement de la première ministre
parce que les chiffres sont terrifiants
ce que vous avez rappelé et ils sont
avérés un enfant toutes les 3 minutes et
victime d'inceste d'agression sexuelle
de violence sexuelle dans notre pays
quand on dit ça on a tous des h cœur on
a même tous franchement envie de vomir
et de crier mais comme on est ici en
responsabilité au lieu de crier et de
vomir et d'avoir des h le cœur on a la
capacité d' agir et pour agir on a
besoin des acteurs on a besoin du
travail de terrain on a besoin des
professionnels donc encore une fois les
arbitrages seront donnés dans quelques
jours je comprends les mois qui peut
vous avoir saisi en tant Commission en
charge de de l'égalité femmes hommes je
crois au Sénat ou des droits des femmes
mais soyez assurés que l'ambition qui
était la NRE il y a 3 ans elle est
encore plus vive
aujourd'hui madame
billon merci monsieur le ministre dans
votre réponse vous dites il y aura une
suite pour moi j'attendais la civice va
se poursuivre su ou ne va pas se
poursuivre je voudrais vous dire qu'une
assemblée ou une institution elle doit
toujours être incarnée pour garantir son
efficacité nous en savons quelque chose
au Sénat le juge Édouard Durand avec son
expertise sa détermination ses
convictions a démontré qu'il était
l'homme de la situation la civice ne
peut se passer du juge Édouard
Duran la parole est à notre collègue
Jacques grosin pour le groupe les
républicains merci président merci
président mesames et messieurs les
ministres mes chers collègues j'aimerais
associer ma question à notre excellent
collègue Stéphan pinoire monsieur le
ministre d'éducation nationale lundi
sont apparus sont ont été publiés donc
les résultats de l'évaluation nationale
sur les élèves de 4e en classe de
mathématiqu et de français vous avez
réagi à à cette annonce là en disant que
vous étiez euh vous trouviez que le
résultat étaient inquiétant et vous avez
même dit que le collège était en
situation donc de difficulté qui
risquait d'être en
je peux vous assurer qu'à ce jour le
collège non pas seulement est en pagne
mais il est véritablement en recul si on
regarde consultation après consultation
évaluation après évaluation depuis des
années on se rend compte véritablement
que les jeunes Français sont en
situation plus difficile et les résultat
baisse pour mémoire en 2000 la France se
situait dans le premier tiers donc au
niveau des des rapports en tout cas des
évaluations de PISA dans les pays de
l'OCDE en 2022 la France se trouve dans
le 2è tiers et parallèlement et si Jos
le dire concomitamment en tout cas le
budget de l'Éducation nationale augmente
véritablement en lorsque vous étiez
lorsque vous êtes arrivé aux affaires en
2018 au PLF le budget était de 51
million d'EUR 51 milliards d'euros en
2024 il est de 63 milliards d'euros soit
plus de 12 milliards d'euros le budget
de la justice trois fois le budget de la
culture on peut s'interroger alors que
parallèlement 404000 élèves de moins
donc sont apparus donc on s'inquiète
donc une seule question monsieur le
ministre deéducation nationale quelles
sont les réformes structurantes et
puissantes que vous allez nous proposer
pour répondre non pas à une crise mais
plutôt à une situation ou un échec
majeur de notre système
éducatif pour répondre la parole est au
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse Monsieur hatal Merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les sénatrices et sénateurs
monsieur le sénateur Jacques gropérin
j'ai eu l'occasion de le dire des ma
nomination au ministère de l'Éducation
nationale et et de la jeunesse mon
objectif c'est l'élévation du niveau
général de nos élèves et tous les
chantiers que j'ai ouvert doivent
concourir à cet objectif quand on
travaille pour restaurer l'attractivité
du métier d'enseignant on agit pour
élever le niveau de nos élèves quand on
travaille pour restaurer l'autorité du
maître à l'école on agit pour
l'élévation du niveau des élèves quand
on réforme le lycée professionnel comme
nous le faisons avec Carole grandjan on
agit pour l'élévation du niveau quand on
agit pour faire respecter les règles de
la République les valeurs de la
République et la laïcité à l'école on
agit pour le niveau des élèves et même
quand on lutte contre le harcèlement
scolaire indépendamment d'agir pour la
dignité des personnes on agit pour
l'élévation du niveau parce qu'un élève
qui est malheureux à l'école c'est un
élève qui ne peut plus apprendre à
l'école les évaluations qui ont été
publiées elles disent deux choses
d'abord elles disent que nous sommes en
train de changer la donne à l'école
primaire positivement la génération 2017
celle qui est entrée au CP quand le
président de la République a été élu en
2017 et que nous avons réinvesti
massivement pour l'école primaire elle
s'en sort mieux que les générations
précédentes évidemment on n'est pas au
bout mais cette génération qui est
rentrée en 6e cette année elle s'en sort
mieux en lecture en écriture et en
calcul que la génération précédente il
faut continuer le collège vous l'avez
dit est un véritable sujet de
préoccupation songez qu'un élève sur qu
à l'entrée en 4e n'a pas le niveau de
lecture attendu en fin de CM2 un élève
sur qu je présenterai au début du mois
de décembre des mesures fortes pour
l'élévation du niveau général à l'école
et au collège je le dis je n'ai aucun
tabou j'ai d'ors et déjà avancé un
certain nombre nombre de pistes sur la
question des manuels scolaires sur la
question de l'organisation en cycle sur
la question des groupes de niveau
j'assume de le dire parce que les
enseignants me le disent avoir dans la
même classe des élèves qui ne savent pas
lire avec des élèves qui lisent très
bien ça ne permet plus de progresser et
ça finit par tirer tout le monde vers le
bas cette proposition fait débat
j'assume de l'avoir mise dans le débat
et je présenterai au début du mois de
décembre des mesures fortes pour que
nous puissions avancer sur cet enjeu qui
est un enjeu pour nos élèves et pour
notre école aujourd'hui mais qui est un
enjeu pour l'avenir de notre pays je
vous remercie mercis bien Monsieur
grosérin Merci monsieur le ministre mais
j'entendais que vous nous parliez
peut-être d'une réforme du collège et la
réforme de ce collège unique qui existe
depuis 1975 et revenir vous nous avez
parlé des groupes de niveau je crois que
c'est pas tabou et vous avez raison de
le dire mais il faut aller encore plus
loin si on me passer d'un collège de la
résilience à un collège de la réussite
il faudra certainement passer par des
réformes structurelles et au sein du
Sénat le rapport Brisson auquel j'étais
rapporteur vous proposera si vous
souhaitez des pistes parce qu'elles sont
efficaces merci merci
la parole est à notre collègue Pierre
Allin Roiron pour le groupe socialiste
écologiste
répu monsieur le Président Madame la
première ministre ma question s'adresse
à madame la ministre des Solidarités des
famille en 2018 le président de la
République avait annoncé je le cite
répondre au défi du vieillissement la
proposition de loi mesure pour bâtir la
société du bien bien vieillir sera
examiner la semaine prochaine à
l'Assemblée nationale une enquête
récente menée par la Fédération
hospitalière de France a révélé que 85 %
des épades se trouvaient en situation
déficitaire à la fin de l'année 2022 ces
déficites tendent à devenir structurel
et croissant dans ce secteur pour ne pas
le dire hélas ils le sont déjà j'ai été
alerté hier de la situation budgétaire
de plusieurs épades dans mon département
je donnerai l'exemple de l'épad de
Richelieu le bilan déficitaire de cetpad
atteint plus de 400000 € dans moins de 3
ans il atteindra son seuil minimal de
fonctionnement et ne sera plus en mesure
de rémunérer ses employés cette
situation alarmante résulte de facteurs
multiples l'inflation des denrées
alimentaires le coût énergétique + 33 %
2023 la revalorisation salariale des
soignants lesqueles n'ont été que très
partiellement
compensé faites-vous le choix de laisser
nos aînés faites-vous le choix de
délaisser le personnel des épades qui
travaillent dans des conditions déjà
très difficiles l'État doit être à la
hauteur de ces enjeux je suis persuadé
que l'ensemble de mes collègues ici
présents dans cette hémistiquele seront
d'accord avec mes propos alors madame la
ministre ma question est simple et
attend une réponse concrète le
gouvernement envisage-t-il de mettre en
œuvre des compensations financières
pérennes et intégrales le gouvernement
compte-il s'attaquer de front à la
question du 3e âge et des épades pour
assurer à nos aînés un accompagnement de
leur vieillissement à la hauteur pour
vous répondre la parole est à la
ministre des solidarités et des familles
madame Aurore berger vous avez la
parole merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Sénateurs
monsieur le le sénateur la question que
vous posez elle est essentielle au
regard du défi démographique qui est
devant nous en 2030 20 millions de
Français auront plus de 60 ans il faut
je crois qu'on sorte collectivement sans
doute d'un défi et d'un dénis individuel
et un dénis collectif et puis vous
l'avez dit il y a la situation très
critique aujourd'hui de nos épades
700000 Français aujourd'hui sont dans
ces établissements on a donc mis en
chose mis en place plusieurs éléments
d'abord un fond d'urgence amorcé et
débloqué par la première ministre des
cette été de 100000 Milon d'euros de
manière à répondre encore une fois à
l'urgence conjoncturelle qui a fait que
l'inflation l'augmentation des
rémunérations la question des prix de
l'énergie et de l'alimentation fait que
parfois on a des situations
conjoncturelles qui méritent une réponse
immédiate évidemment des éléments plus
structurels qu'on a pu annoncer avec la
première ministre lors des Assises des
départements de France la semaine
dernière deux réponses dès 2024 nous
allons augmenter la compensation de
l'État parce que nous allons via la CNSA
augmenter de 150000 millions d'euros les
compensations du au département au titre
de l'APA et de la PCH et puis surtout
une refonte en profondeur des fonds de
concours que nous amorçons avec
l'ensemble des présidents de département
pour 2025 pour enfin que les fonds de
concours aient du sens qu'ils soient
moins nombreux en gros on arrête
d'empiler des fonds de concours et des
politiques publiques pour avoir des
politiques publiques beaucoup plus
lisibles et augmenter ainsi la prise en
charge qui sera faite par l'État ce que
nous avons mis sur la table et je crois
que les départements sont en accord avec
cette proposition c'est qu'à partir de
50 % de toutes les dépenses nouvelles au
titre de l'autonomie soit pris en charge
par l'État via la CNSA c'est un
engagement majeur que l'État va prendre
qui est en corrélation encore une fois
avec le le défi démographique qui est
devant nous vous l'avez dit on reprend
l'examen à partir de lundi d'une
proposition de loi qui pose des bases
importantes sociétales et de
reconnaissance des professionnels je ne
doute pas que ce sera enrichi évidemment
au Sénat du moins je l'espère et enrichi
aussi dans le casadre de nos échanges
sur le PLFSS notamment avec la fusion
des sections soins et dépendan par
exemple je vous remercie la parole est à
notre collègue Christina Pluchet pour le
groupe merci merci monsieur le Président
ma question s'adresse à monsieur le
ministre de l'Agriculture et de la
souveraineté
alimentaire monsieur le ministre le 8
novembre dernier par la voix de sa
présidente Madame vlen la Commission
européenne a recommandé officiellement
l'ouverture des négociations d'adhésion
avec l'Ukraine cet avis favorable doit
être ensuite approuvé à l'unanimité par
les 27 lors du Conseil du prochain
Conseil européen les 14 et 15 décembre à
Bruxelles sans évoquer la question
diplomatique que pose cette initiative
dans un contexte de recherche de paix et
de désamorçage du conflit je souhaiterit
vous poser la question fondamentale de
la préservation de nos intérêts
agricoles vous revenez d'Ukraine vous
avez annoncé je cite uvreer au
renforcement de la coopération agricole
entre nos deux pays travailler avec eux
sur le chemin de l'adhésion à l'Union
européenne an est invoquer la solidarité
des agriculteurs dans le contexte de
l'ouverture du marché européen aux
produits agricoles
Ukrainiens monsieur le ministre
pourriez-vous nous éclairer sur vos
intentions si la position favorable de
la France ne fait désormais aucun doute
êtes-vous bien conscient du désarroi des
agriculteurs français pris en éto entre
des normes européennes toujours plus
exigeantes et complexes une ouverture
toujours plus grande à la concurrence
avec la multiplication des accords de
libre échange et une envolée du coup des
intrants et de
l'énergie monsieur le ministre quels
intérêts
défendez-vous votre dernière déclaration
largement relayée par vos soins sur les
réseaux sociaux sonne comme une volte
face pour de nombreux syndicats
agricoles nous ne pouvons pas prendre le
risque de sacrifier nos intérêts comment
allez-vous protéger l'agriculture
française dans une telle
perspective pour vous répondre la parole
ministre de l'Agriculture de la
souveraineté alimentaire monsieur F
merci monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs madame la
sénatrice merci de votre question il y a
aucune volte face au contraire je suis
venu en Ukraine réaffirmer plusieurs
choses d'abord à la vérité en Ukraine se
joue beaucoup de choses qui qui relèv de
l'avenir de l'Europe et de l'avenir de
l'agriculture en Europe et de
l'agriculture française aussi la
première chose que je suis venu dire en
Ukraine c'est le soutien indéfectible de
la France et de l'Europe à l'agriculture
et aux agriculteurs Ukrainiens quand
vous êtes sur des territoires ù du fait
des bombardements du fait de la
pollution j'étais dans une chèvrerie où
le la ligne de front était à 500 m voyez
bien dans quelles conditions produisent
ces agriculteurs ça me paraît la moindre
des choses que de dire que nous sommes à
leur côté y compris dans la
reconstruction y compris dans la
dépollution pour que le potentiel
agricole ukrainien puisse se faire 2è
élément de la réponse parce que la
solidarité n'empêche pas la lucidité sur
les enjeux qui sont les nôtres et donc
la lucidité qui sont qui sur les enjeux
fait que l'Ukraine est l'une des grandes
puissances agricoles mondiales et que
dans la perspective de négociation qui
pourrait s'ouvrir attendons les
décisions du Conseil euh du mois de
décembre dans la perspective de ce qui a
été les préconisations de la Commission
européenne il faut être vigilant à deux
ch ch la première c'est qu'il n'est pas
possible que dans cet objectif là il n'y
ait pas de convergence des modèles et
donc des contraintes qui seraient lié à
l'agriculture ukrainienne comme elle
elle se pèse ou elle se propose sur le
continent européen l'union de l'Union à
27 sinon évidemment on aurait des
distorsions de concurrence qui seraient
trop faibl et donc il faut qu'on
accompagne nos amis ukrainiens et nos
amis agriculteurs Ukrainiens dans une
convergence sinon évidemment on aurait
des distorsions qui seraient trop fortes
et donc c'est un élément qui est un
élément important c'est comme les
clauses miroir sur les accords de
commerce deuxième élément il y a de
solutions soit on rentre dans cette
logique là en coopération avec les
Ukrainiens parce que nous avons besoin
de que l'Europe soit plus encore une
puissance agricole une puissance qui
garantisse sa souveraineté et la
sécurité alimentaire y compris à s
frontièrees parce que je préfère
travailler avec des alliés comme les
Ukrainiens qu'avec d'autres qui vont
nous faire une pression alimentaire sur
la sécurité alimentaire comme c'est le
cas aujourd'hui de Monsieur Poutine à
nos frontières extérieures et donc si on
arrive à coopérer plutôt qu'à rentrer en
concurrence si on arrive à faire
converger les modèles on y gagnera tous
et donc c'est bien ça qui est l'enjeu et
c'est bien ça que je suis venu
réaffirmer y compris en à mes
interlocuteurs les distorsions de
concurrence qui aujourd'hui pénalisé je
pense à la volaille ou je pense à
d'autres domaines le sucre par exemple
que vous connaissez bien dans votre
région qui peuvent pénaliser nos
agriculteurs discours de vérérité et
discours de souveraineté collectif merci
Madame plucher oui merci merci monsieur
le ministre pour votre réponse mais moi
je voulais rappeler je voudrais vous
rappeler une petite chose depuis que
l'Union européenne a suspendu les droits
de douane par solidarité à l'Ukraine
aujourd'hui on a le poulet industriel je
dis bien industriel ukrainien qui a FL
sur le marché français au détriment de
notre filière d'excellence donc il est
vraiment temps de défendre avec force
l'agriculture française notre
souveraineté alimentaire doit être une
vraie priorité nationale merci
merci la parole est à notre collègue
Bruno rejoint pour le groupe les
républicains monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse à
Monsieur le Ministre du
Logement devant le fiasco de votre
politique du logement je vais vous en
rajouter une couche monsieur le ministre
en effet sommet de se mettre aux normes
dans des délais intenables les petits
propriétaires bailleurs concernés par
les rénovations thermiques ils sont
nombreux en France font leur compte et
ça ne passe pas en terme d'équilibre
financier si pour les secteurs
géographiques des métropoles avec des
loyers plutôt élevé on peut peut-être
tendre vers un équilibre sur un nombre
de acceptable ce n'est absolument pas le
cas dans des départements ruraux comme
le mien et d'autres en raison du faible
niveau des revenus et surtout des loyers
ces deux secteurs ont malheureusement un
point commun c'est que le coût des
travaux voyez-vous est quasiment le même
comme le montrent les devis réalisés ma
question est simple monsieur le ministre
qu'allez-vous faire pour que la ruralité
ne soit pas une fois de plus pénalisée
par une politique nationale
pour vous répondre la parole est au
ministre délégé en charge du logement
Patrice
vergrit monsieur le monsieur le
Président Mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs et sénatrices monsieur le
sénateur rejoint voilà je vous cherchais
du
regard le sujet que vous évoquez est
effectivement important la rénovation
énergétique des logements au secteur
rural je le disais moi-même ici dans
dans cette hémicycle il y a une semaine
dans un département comme la Creuse
c'est plus d'un logement sur deux
aujourd'hui qui a un classement en
diagnosti de performance énergétique de
niveau F ou G donc on voit effectivement
l'enjeu le gouvernement y répond à
travers de nombreuses mesures et en
particulier la réforme de l'aide à la
rénovation énergétique qui va se mettre
en œuvre à partir du 1er janvier 2024 il
répond déjà très concrètement prenons un
exemple puisque c'est cette aide pourra
aller jusqu'à 4 90 % du montant des
travaux pour les ménages très modestes
que vous avez évoqué dans votre question
mais prenons un exemple d'un ménage de
classe moyenne entre le 5e ou le 8e
desciles le montant des de l'aide par
rapport au travaux sera de 60 % donc
pour 55000 € de travaux on peut imaginer
33000 € d'aide auquel on peut agiter
évidemment l'aide des collectivités
locales qui peut exister mais aussi par
exemple puisque vous avez évoqué des
loyer modéré l'aide du dispositif loc
avantage qui permet de bonifier cette
aide je aajoute qu'ensuite sur le reste
à charge nous avons prolongé l'écoprêt à
taux zéro aujourd'hui et puis surtout le
dispositif fiscal du déficit foncier que
vous connaissez qui permet de déduire
les charges des travaux des revenus
locatifs et doubler jusqu'en jevier 2025
pour des travaux qui permettraient
d'atteindre la performance de classe D
si j'ajoute à ça le de Normandie que
nous avons également poursuivi
dispositif fiscal la prime à la sortie
de la vacance il y a une multiplicité d'
qui permettent d'aborder effectivement
ces enjeux- là aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il faut les saisir tous la loi
logement permettra si ce n'était pas
suffisant de renforcer encore ces
dispositifs pour la ruralité vous voyez
monsieur le sénateur la ruralité n'est
pas abandonnée loin s'en faut je vous en
remercie Monsieur rejoint j'aimerais
vous croire Monsieur le Ministre mais
voyez-vous ce gouvernement dans le
domaine du logement a réussi un triple
exploit jamais inégalé aujourd'hui la
construction de logement neuf est
bloquée l'achat vente de logement ancien
est au plus bas depuis des décennies et
là vous nous faites entrer dans un
blocage du locatif avec une situation
qui va être dramatique donc tous les
clignotants sont au rouge alors
voyez-vous en politique comme ailleurs
il n'y a aucune honte à essayer de
corriger un certain nombre de
dispositifs qui ont été mis en place ce
serait tout à votre honneur ce serait
aussi faire preuve de courage et en
politique le courage souvent ça
paye
[Musique]
merci merci madame la Première ministre
mesdames et messieurs les ministres nous
avons terminé avec les questions au
Gouvernement nos prochaines questions
auront lieu le vercredi 22 novembre à
2023 15h précises je vais suspendre la
séance sera reprise à 16h30 pour la
suite de l'examen du projet de loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale pour
2024 la séance est
suspendue voilà pour cette séance de
questions au gouvernement que vous avez
pu suivre en direct et en intégralité
sur Public Sénat place au débrief et
tout de suite direction la salle des
conférences pour rejoindre Quentin calm
car Quentin vous êtes avec et bien le
ministre qui passe sa semaine au Sénat à
l'occasion de l'examin du budget de la
Sécurité sociale c'est le ministre de la
santé et de la prévention Aurélien
Rousseau oui bonjour Aurélien Rousseau
merci de venir à ce micro pour une
réaction en direct un mot sur le vote
hier au Sénat du projet de loi
immigration avec un nouvel article le 1i
qui vient supprimer l'aide médicale
d'État remplacée par une aide médicale
d'urgence une réaction à cette
suppression vous l'avez déjà fait dans
les médias mais vous voulez maintenant
qu'elle revienne cette ame dans le texte
de l'Assemblée nationale oui le texte
initial du gouvernement ne présentez pas
cette cette mesure d'abord c'est une
mesure qui concerne le code de la santé
publique c'est pas ça n'a je crois pas
grandchose à faire dans un texte sur
l'immigration parce que s'il y a un
point qui est aujourd'hui assez
documenté c'est que le fait que la me
n'est pas une pas quelque chose qui crée
de l'attractivité à l'immigration et
puis l'ame c'est un dispositif qui
soigne les gens les personnes mais c'est
aussi un dispositif de santé publique
c'est pour ça que la différence
fondamentale pour moi avec la mu c'est
qu'il faut que les médecins libéraux les
les médecins de ville restent dans la
boucle de la prise en charge de ces
personnes et qu'on ne renvoie pas tout
sur l'hôpital au risque de mettre
l'hôpital en grande difficulté les LR
disent qu'ils pourrai en faire une ligne
rouge dans la version finale du projet
de dois immigration qu'est-ce que vous
leur répondez ils disent aussi
d'ailleurs qu'il y a un volet prévention
dans l'Aide médicale d'urgence qu'ils
ont mis à la place de la me écoutez pour
l'instant moi je je je ne vois pas
précisément ce point dans leur dans leur
proposition euh j'ai entendu le
président du Sénat ce matin évoquer
qu'il aurait quand même un contact
préalable avec un médecin ce qui
constitue déjà quelque chose de
nouveau le débat va se poursuivre à
l'Assemblée national chacun a des lignes
de différentes couleurs en tête en tout
cas pour le gouvernement il est clair
que l'aide médicale d'État est un
dispositif on peut toujours en discuter
on peut toujours l'améliorer mais c'est
un dispositif essentiel de santé
publique Tam le disait il y a un instant
vous passez votre semaine au Sénat car
le Sénat a commencé l'examen du projet
loi de financement de la sécurité
sociale on a vu des questions à ce sujet
lors de cette séance on a entendu par
exemple les socialistes dire queon était
dans et bien avec des vagues de mauvais
résultats dans un océan de déficit
c'est-à-dire des Français moins bien
soignés et des déficits qui se creusent
ici 2027 qu'est-ce que vous répondez je
réponds que la l'hôpital et l'hôpital
public en particulier il est en
difficulté il y a aucun déni là-dessus
euh pour moi les les des questions de
sénateurs socialiste par ailleurs
montrer une forme de contradiction entre
l'idée il y a des déficites mais l'idée
on prend de moins en moins bien en
charge les Français oui on est dans un
pays dans lequel la population vieillit
dans lequel il y a de plus en plus de
maladies chroniques mais l'hôpital ça
n'est pas juste ce terrain de ruine qui
est parfois décrit dans l'hémicycle on a
des augmentations de recrutement on est
en train de rouvrir des lits donc je
pense qu'il faut aussi parfois non pas
pour être dans le dénis sur les
difficultés mais être capable aussi
parfois de dire qu'il y a des choses qui
se passent à l'hôpital et qui sont
positives une dernière question il nous
reste quelques secondes mais est-ce
qu'on pourrait avoir de nouvelles
annonces sur le financement de la santé
des Français on avait vu la piste de
relever de doubler la franchise médicale
est-ce que c'est toujours sur la table
est-ce qu'il pourrait y avoir de
nouvelles annonces dans les prochaines
semaines C il manque toujours 800
millions d'euros dans le budget cette
piste elle est elle est sur la table ce
que le président République à Premier
ministre et je me suis appliqué à le
redire comme Thomas CASNAV c'est que
nous attendons d'avoir la vision globale
du débat et notamment dans une période
où nos compatriotes sont très préoccupés
par les questions de pouvoir d'achat on
veut avant de lancer les concertations
nécessaires sur cet éventuel doublement
des franchises avoir la vision globale
sur les textes financiers et bien merci
merci pour cette réaction au micro de
public merci Monsieur le Ministre merci
merci beaucoup Quentin pour cette
première réaction effectivement à votre
micro et autre réaction celle du
président du groupe les républicains
Bruno retaillot qui s'installe le voilà
Bruno rotillot le président du groupe LR
à votre micro Quentin oui bonjour Bruno
merci de venir ici au micro de Public
Sénat un mot sur ce vote du projet de
loi immigration ça y est le Sénat a voté
sa copie du texte toute la question est
maintenant de savoir ce qui va se passer
à l'Assemblée nationale on a vu certains
députés LR hésiter pour eux et bien le
texte ne va pas assez à droite ça
rappelle un peu la réforme des retraites
non non pas du tout très franchement le
texte est arrivé avec 27 articles de
Monsieur Darmanin sur les 27 on en a
modifié beaucoup et on en a tellement
ajouté qu'il va faire maintenant une
centaine d'articles c'est pas le texte
de Monsieur Darman qu'on va voter qu'on
a voté c'est notre texte et jamais
jamais de mémoire de députés ou de
sénateurs LR nous av'avions été la
droite aussi ferme on a durci un texte
et j'attends de nos amis députés bien
sûr qu'il le soutiennent et s'il est
détricoté surtout qu'il s'y oppose avec
la dernière énergie pourquoi est-ce
qu'urélien Pradier il parle de reculade
et il parle sur France Info d'un texte
de centriste il dit que c'est le texte
des centristes c'est écoutez com on dit
chez moi vaut mieux entendre de ça que
d'être sourd voilà il faut qu'il
travaille qu' le lise et s'il a un peu
d'objectivité il verra que ce que nous
avons inséré dans ce texte très
franchement le retour sur les
nationalité du dispositif pasquis la fin
de laame le durcissement du recoubant
familial le leur rétablissement du délit
de séjour pour séjour justement
irrégulier et cetera et cetera non c'est
c'est c'est c'est comique une
plaisanterieou alors il va y avoir une
autre difficulté dans l'examen du texte
à l'Assemblée nationale c'est
effectivement l'aile gauche de
renaissance qui souhaite remettre des
choses dans le texte alors l'aide
médicale d'État mais aussi une autre
version de l'article 3 est-ce que vous
fixez des lignes rouges très nettes sur
certaines choses dans le texte il y a
pas une ligne rouge on a essayé de
reprendre parce que c'est les Français
qui nous le demandent ils considèrent
que il y a trop d'immigration en France
on a essayé d'avoir une politique
globale qui doit être complétée par une
réforme constitutionnelle donc que vous
examinerez en décembre tout se tient où
on a la maîtrise des instruments
juridiques qui vont nous permettre de
réguler l'immigration ou alors le texte
il est troué c'est-à-dire que il y a des
brèches partout et croyez-moi on on se
prépare un avenir aussi bien en matière
de flux migratoire mais aussi politique
qui sera un avenir qui ne sera pas
brillant mais laame remplacé par une
aide médicale d'urgence est-ce que c'est
une ligne rouge entendais le ministre
qui souhaite revenir sur cet aspect du T
ça ça fait partie ça fait partie des
mesures qui nous permettent d'arrêter
d'être le mieux disant européen parce
que ça les filières de passeur le repère
nous sur la me mais sur aussi beaucoup
d'autres dispositifs on a essayé
d'amener le dispositif français à ne pas
être parmi les mieux disants mais à
rentrer dans une convergence européenne
voilà parce que sinon si on est les
mieux disants si on est le pays le plus
avantageux ben évidemment on continuera
d'attirer on est déjà à pratiquement un
demimillion par an est-ce qu'on en veut
plus non les Français dans une grande
majorité y compris d'ailleurs les
Français qui votent à gauche un dernier
mot Éric soti qui ne ser rend pas
vendredi aux rencontres de Saint-Denis
qu'est-ce que ça vous évoque vous êtes
d'accord avec le président de votre
parti écoutez je lui fais confiance oui
oui non mais il a pris cette décision à
partir du moment où avec Emmanuel Macron
euh la politique est réduite si j'ose
dire à beaucoup de communication il a un
moment donné on peut pas pour exprimer
ce que en vandé on dit dans une belle
expression vandéenne on peut pas
continuer à promener le brochet dans les
temps d'accord vous auriez été président
du parti vous auriez pris la même
décision écoutez je ne suis pas donc
mais en tout cas cette décision ne m'a
pas choqué très bien merci brunoo pour
cette réaction au micro de public s
merci merci merci beaucoup Quentin pour
cette nouvelle réaction et puis on va
maintenant parler d'un sujet qui a
occupé pas moins de trois questions au
Gouvernement cet après-midi on a vu tous
les sénateur du du Pas de Calais qui
était mobilisé sur ce sujet et notamment
la sénatrice Amel gaker qui est à votre
micro Quentin elle a interpellé le
Gouvernement sur ce sujet de ces
inondations qui durent et qui durent
dans le pas decalais oui bonjour Amel
gaka un mot sur ce que vous ont dit les
ministres qui ont répondu au ces
questions d'actualité aujourd'hui on
retient notamment l'idée d'un projet de
loi futur sur le curage des cours d'eau
c'est quelque chose que vous attendez
dans le département du ptecalais bonjour
oui tout à fait alors ça c'est un
élément de réponse qui a été apporté
aujourd'hui et qui répond à une vraie
attente de nos élus hier j'étais
présente lors de la
séquence de l'accueil en fait du
président au sein de notre département
et une forte attente a été évoquée de
simplifier véritablement et aujourd'hui
nos élus en meurent en fait et de
pouvoir entretenir des cours d'eau sans
être systématiquement empêché par trop
de normes et trop de réglementation ça
vous pouvez nous expliquer en quelques
mots rapides mais vous voulez de la
simplification administrative